qué se está viendo en las últimas horas
en esa frontera y que les transmiten a
ustedes los migrantes ante el final del
título 42
Gracias Rodrigo por la invitación este
lo que se está viendo es una crisis muy
grande la gente está desesperada
tratando de llegar a la frontera y
muchos tratando ya de Cruz Bueno lo que
se ha visto el día de hoy de cómo cruzan
hacia Estados Unidos y cómo este Border
pachón los detiene y devuelve nuevamente
a México lo que se va a ver este estos
días va a ser una situación
bastante crítica bastante difícil
bueno durante esta semana se ha hablado
mucho de las dificultades que plantea el
cambio de normativa está entendiendo la
mayoría de la gente el cambio de normas
o falta que la información Se extienda
más entre las personas
hay una confusión bastante grande porque
hasta ayer se hablaba del título ocho
del miedo creíble de solicitarlo ahí en
el en la frontera de presentar tu cita
de cvp One y listo Hoy en día pues ya
cambió O sea hay un cambio constante que
lo que ha traído es confusión para la
población migrante no están las las
reglas claras por parte del gobierno de
Estados Unidos Lamentablemente Esto está
trayendo mucho caos y confusión con la
población migrante en el país
y temen quizás ahora todas estas
personas quedarse en un limbo fronterizo
entre las dos fronteras
este entre las dos fronteras
usar y este pensar que están una vez que
están dentro en la detención este pensar
que con la entrevista Ya ellos pueden
Ingresar a Estados Unidos y la realidad
es otra totalmente distinta porque ya
hay un acuerdo entre el gobierno de
México y Estados Unidos de manera clara
que México va a recibir 30.000 personas
por mes es decir mil por días por cada
día entonces lo que se espera es una
deportación masiva mensual ahí ahí este
una situación muy complicada para las
personas que están ingresando o que
piensan ingresar esta madrugada a
Estados Unidos de manera irregular Se le
pide a la gente pues que no lo haga